Trash Talk Nation this is a very special
episode of trash talk you're about to
see we were in Canada Gary decided he
wanted to go out thrift shopping and in
a matter of moments we were in a car on
our way I think that's one of the great
things about trash talk and if you live
in a town where maybe you don't want to
wait for the weekend to go to a garage
sale these videos really are intended to
teach you how to go and make money any
day of the week this is my second time
shooting Trash Talk stepping in for the
illustrious drock hope you enjoy it
Trash Talk
[Music]
how many villages are there in Toronto
many good we're gonna go to the mall I
think I really think thrifting on a
Saturday if you really get knowledgeable
about a lot of categories
is a two three hundred dollar Saturday I
mean me and AJ ate poor AJ because I
saved me and AJ agent did the [ __ ]
posting and shipping [ __ ] digital
camera take out the disc put in the
computer slow internet now dude
your [ __ ] phone while you're eating a
[ __ ] Tim Hortons Burger you know like
[ __ ] is Tim Hortons sell burgers
Value Village vaynerchuk
you're big on mugs man I'm a huge on mug
it's an easy thing to learn
oh but right again this is where you
decide you want to listen for 15 and sit
on it for a while
you know but this I'd probably buy
because Christmas is coming up and I'd
probably put it yeah let's take
it
[Music]
but this one Smurf okay here is this one
I know what it is it's a 1982 Pao smart
figurine some of them are quite rare
yeah this bag of 4.99 between that
[Music]
is that a Pokemon like this is a winning
bag a little older yeah we're gonna take
this we'll break it down later I'm
excited to do the homework in the bag
that I just grabbed
and that's what you have to do when you
first start because you don't know
anything you've got to take a couple
risks just to learn
what made you draw that one out this
yeah
yeah I appeal
right just like you just know that
people like skeletons you know that [ __ ]
adds up
foreign
this is 20 bucks
the amount of hipsters in Brooklyn you
know this Nema yeah
this is like exactly where people pay 40
for in a actually fits nicely should be
able this Mario have this [ __ ]
flexible
Toronto thrift stores like what get that
I'm just gonna kill
life
gotta love it how bad for 30 minutes all
right now one of my favorite things to
do is these little fun packs they get
for 4.99 you get really start to break
them down this is one of the risks but
again for a lot of people watching it's
not for lost because this is what he
learned in this dinosaur racer
and again this goes to marketing you
take this picture underneath and you go
here and you go you know vintage retro
old rare you know dinosaur some people
know which dinosaur this is
um 80s 90s eraser you put this for 15
bucks on Etsy I'm telling you it sells
oh this is what I was hoping for Pokemon
[ __ ]
do you guys know which Pokemon this is
[Music]
here we go
this one's like ten dollars
10 10 and maybe somebody saw it you'd
probably get 10 for that one as well but
you know no big deal this is 25 bucks
plus shipping plus five dollars to be
shipping I'm gonna look up Garfield
cabbage okay I'm gonna look up the Smurf
but I'm just gonna play and say this is
another 10. 45 15. here's the thing
again this keeps going down to what I'm
trying to say a lot of people on Earth
today are making minimum wage 12 13 an
hour we're an hour all in now
like all that work we stayed in the
store for a little while the driving but
we're like at 50 here all that but
here's the thing the education starts to
build
you know five minutes ago he didn't know
that this was worth 35 guess what
happens four months from now when you go
to a garage sale and there's a 50 of
these in a bag for 10 bucks
didn't go straight for the toys
always the mugs
so you get into a place like like this
Heineken hat that's a big one you like
this I do like that eight I'm [ __ ]
Marty's Hat's so goddamn expensive I'm
pissed right now this is again this is
where a garage sale
is like 25 50 cents a hat
Toronto's trying to get ridiculous on us
here you're only moving a sneaker stuff
right I would love to but like I don't
know
garyvee
do it man
nice to meet you man can I get a picture
with you okay
[Music]
thank you brother
[Music]
it's garyvee
[Music]
the thing that I really wanted that I'm
not into yet is t-shirts one
paper
shirts it's all pop culture it's why the
whole
that's why be friends come so much
6 49 for 20.
holy [ __ ] this could be good
14 bucks so world
what's it for 5 49. to me I like at
least 10 20 profit because with the fees
and everything but it's right on that
border but again that one's over 13.99
you can list this for 22 bucks the
hardcore Brian Adams band buys it for
taking it you can see like right away
like we're not doing as well here this
tells me like this is like a understood
location like this location feels as
though there may be more flippers that
come through why it just feels like I
don't see as many
things available you know what I mean
yep
the board game's a big thing
the winner here Nema
condition matters for board games yeah
matters for everything you're looking
for vintage games yeah 1976 cool years
from 8 to 24. if you're willing to have
it sit in your house you'll get your
price when people see eight and twenty
cool like if you want to sell it quick
you go free if I bought that for one
dollar maybe I go 15 get it out but if I
buy for five okay put it for 20 plus
Christmas is coming all of a sudden
maybe that's 25.
11 28 on two board games vintage
all day
let me find a [ __ ]
I can tell you already it's not going to
be a good garage sale let me tell you
why because of the sign it means these
people do garage sales all the time I
promise when we go right now it's gonna
feel more like a flea market than a
garage sale
but we'll see
hello hello hi hello hi how you doing
what are you looking so much
twenty dollars for the pins I don't
think so
there's too many I tell you what what 30
dollars are all yours but there's over
30 here
that's what I'm saying three dollars
over here
there's not any man enough here
yeah
25 bucks I can't go no lower you got 25
bucks on you somebody had 25 bucks five
dollars here five ten fifteen twenty
twenty five there you go if you don't
have it there's got to be a bank close
took us a few minutes to get the cash
but boy oh boy you have no idea what
just happened
people don't understand that pins
are insane it would be 25 for all these
pins I cannot wait
to show Nema the first one
first pin four dollars
this is the fun part for you this is the
best part for me it's gonna
us first Germany World Cup pin
CH your money back if you both hold 63
of those and they're averaging for five
to seven let's just say 63 at seven it's
4 24. like this this is easily 250 and a
bulk set that somebody takes if they're
into piz
25 250.
that's good
but you're not going
to not getting then I reply or when you
want to teach people how to fish you
know the best part of being on the
receiving end of cynicism is when it's
not true if I was doing that post to get
likes or 8 000 likes well then there's
nothing to tell there's no reply to talk
about I can't be mad at somebody
[Music]
I gotta love them back the reason the
world's struggling right now is fear and
hate on fear
fear iron hand feared like where's love
in the equation
[Music]
I
know you're on the road
[Music]